LIZ FONG-JONES: Hi there.
I'm Liz, a Site Reliability
Engineer, or SRE, at Google.
And I teach Google
Cloud customers
how to build and operate
reliable services.
SETH VARGO: And I'm
Seth, a Developer
Advocate at Google focused on
infrastructure and operations.
And Liz and I are here to
settle things once and for all.
Which is better, DevOps or SRE?
LIZ FONG-JONES:
Whoa there, Seth.
Hold on a second.
I'm not sure you're
really looking
at this in the right way.
But first of all, maybe we
should clarify some things.
What do you think DevOps is?
SETH VARGO: So that's
a great question, Liz.
Back in the day,
operators and developers
had a lot of contention.
Developers used to
throw their code
over the metaphorical
wall, and operators
were responsible for
keeping that code running
in production.
Operators had little
understanding of the code
bases, and developers
had little understanding
of operational practices.
But developers were
concerned with shipping code,
and operators were
concerned with reliability.
This misalignment
often caused tension
within the organization.
LIZ FONG-JONES: So if I
understand you correctly,
you're saying that
the developers were
responsible for features,
and the operators
were responsible for stability,
meaning the developers wanted
to move faster to get
their features out faster
and the operators wanted to move
slower to keep things stable?
I could see how that would
cause a lot of tension.
SETH VARGO: Exactly.
So DevOps is a set of practices
and a culture designed
to break down those barriers
between developers, operators,
and other parts of
the organization.
I break DevOps down
into five key areas.
First, reduce
organizational silence.
By breaking down
barriers across teams,
we can increase collaboration
and thorough put.
Second, accept
failure as normal.
Computers are
inherently unreliable,
so we can't expect perfection.
And when we introduce
humans into the system,
we get even more imperfection.
Third, implement gradual change.
Not only are small, incremental
changes easier to review,
but in the event that
a gradual change does
make a bug in
production, it allows
us to reduce our
mean time to recover,
making it simple to roll back.
Fourth, we need to leverage
tooling and automation.
And fifth, we need to
measure everything.
Measurement is a critical
gauge for success.
And without a way to measure
if our first four pillars
were successful, we would have
no way of knowing if they were.
So, Liz, you've been an SRE at
Google for over 10 years now.
Do you think any of the way
that I described DevOps aligns
with your experience as an SRE?
LIZ FONG-JONES: It's
sounding very familiar.
Because, if you think about
DevOps as a philosophy,
SRE is a prescriptive way of
accomplishing that philosophy.
So if DevOps were an interface
in programming language,
you might almost say that
SRE is a concrete class that
implements DevOps.
Let's take a look
at how that is.
So, Seth, when you
talked about eliminating
organizational silos,
what I thought about
is the fact that we share
ownership of production
with our developers.
And we use the same
tooling in order
to make sure everyone has the
same view and same approach
to working with production.
When you talked about
accepting accidents and failure
as normal, what I thought
about is the fact that--
similar to many
DevOps practitioners--
we have blameless
postmortems, where
we make sure that the failures
that happen in our production
systems don't happen the
exact same way more than once.
And we accept the failures
as normal by encoding
a concept of an error budget of
how much the system is allowed
to go out of spec.
And then third, we talked
about making gradual changes.
And when you said that,
I thought about the fact
that we canary
things, that we roll
things out to a small
percentage of the fleet
before we move them
out for all users.
And then fourth, when you
talked about leveraging
tooling and automation,
what I thought about
is the fact that we try
to eliminate manual work
as much as possible.
So we measure how
much toil we have,
and then we try to automate
this year's job away.
And then fifth, when you talked
about measuring everything,
I thought about exactly
that measurement
of measuring the amount
of toil that we have
and measuring the reliability
and health of our systems.
SETH VARGO: I really like that.
Class SRE implements DevOps.
We should get that on
a shirt or something.
But just like a class in
a programming language,
there might be additional
functions or methods
that don't necessarily
correspond to that interface.
Or the class might implement
multiple interfaces.
Do you think SRE is like that?
LIZ FONG-JONES: I
absolutely think
that's the case
because of the fact
that SRE doesn't do things
in the exact same way
that other people that
implement DevOps elsewhere
might want to do.
So we'll talk a little bit
more about those differences,
such as how exactly
SLOs work, which
are a very specific concept
that we implement in order
to make SRE successful.
SETH VARGO: Great.
Well, that settles it, then.
It turns out that DevOps and SRE
aren't two competing methods,
but rather close
friends designed
to help break down
organizational barriers
to deliver better
software faster.
Thank you, everyone,
for watching.
Please be sure to
check the description
below for more links,
and don't forget
to subscribe to our channel.
Stay tuned for our
next video, where
we will discuss the differences
between SLIs, SLOs, and SLAs.